two live crew having sex on stage they
got a video of this [ __ ] on the internet
like what is that what they're gonna
flow what's happening
[ __ ] ass or something on the floor
man yeah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i told
i really admire these guys so much oh my
master's
[Music]
i'm mike tyson i'm chilling with brother
freddie gibbs
damn this [ __ ] crazy man
did you just smoke out of your fights
i never smoked there in my face when i
first started like the last the last
year of my career i started smoking weed
and fighting oh [ __ ] i wish i did it at
the beginning why is that
just relaxing i'm gonna be so stressed
and [ __ ] that's real man they test you
for weed though in the boxing room no
more
that's crazy yeah they'll test in the
nba they're they'll feel the boy he's
got hurt
yeah that's what i heard
so what you doing man man i'm just
telling man i'm just been shooting this
mini film all week i just uh shot a
two tv shows getting into the acting
world thing real heavy
working on my album too so my new album
we're gonna talk about that
i watched your fight to roy jones joy
thank you brother thank you that was a
good that was a good entertaining fight
too
yeah i was trying to get older phil to
do this stuff but he wouldn't listen to
him damn man holyfield man
that was a bad loss for me
listen to me have some money and have
some dignity yeah man but you i think
you would
i don't know man you was looking real he
was looking real in shape at that fight
man so i wasn't really [ __ ] you wouldn't
say i wasn't that's what i'm saying i
was like man like roy was like oh man
this [ __ ]
yeah they think they should either get
back in shape yeah
you know what the [ __ ] they're 30 years
younger than you beating on your ass
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah man amanda that was
a bad fight man it was it was
he looked good he ain't look like he was
in shape for that fight either you
playing that ball state university
played football for you
before i made my exit from college into
the rap world i just you and the other
[ __ ] joey badass you have some iridite
rappers your [ __ ] been to
school and graduated all that [ __ ]
don't have no [ __ ] real thug
etiquette and [ __ ]
this is this new era of the [ __ ]
rappers huh
hey man
rappers are turning into no this stage
of rapper but i'm saying i know it's
gonna sound corny since i was saw that
[ __ ] yesterday there's no talking to
him if they gonna reach their form of
black excellence because they [ __ ]
ain't talking like we used to talk in
the 80s
you [ __ ] got fences periods they
blocked these [ __ ] out of talking
about before but now [ __ ] that they
shit's moving [ __ ] pop and they get it
real you know you know i talked like
that i thought we got to look at these
[ __ ] i'm talking to him
oh these ain't no [ __ ] real type of
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're from the place you
know that [ __ ] they got the they got
the certification being born in the
right place but these [ __ ] are
different they i'm not used to these
kind of these [ __ ] college smart
[ __ ] right
i hit it i feel it right away as soon as
i talk to them this [ __ ] ain't no
ordinary [ __ ]
you know that though you know that
man you know i got you know i'm
definitely smarter than the average
[ __ ] i know i'll say that oh yeah yeah
i bet you do
you got to be smart to run a business
though man i understand that but i've
seen um
let's think about i think the beginning
of this game
and i just counted my hand to people
that from the beginning like again how
many people rappers i've met from the
beginning since it started and i call
any kind of handful that got a business
yeah there was thousands of them yeah
nobody never sustained no
it's hard i mean [ __ ] what do you do
life after rap though you got to think
about that ain't no like rap pensioning
or [ __ ] like no it's not about that but
that's the platform true you take that
platform and go to the next stage
definitely first thing they may have you
rapping in a movie playing yourself next
thing you know you're the drug dealer
you're the kingpin that's been you know
your number one film box office yeah man
that's how it's going so far it's like
you know my future or something it's
like you got a crystal ball or some [ __ ]
no i i've been there i've seen it before
i've seen the ride
yeah you used to [ __ ] with tupac so you
seen it yeah
oh two boxes
a beautiful cat
you know all these years since right we
got nobody left to impact like big in
tupac
no i don't think so now that's the
impact like that
i mean you know
jay-z
and
they did um
when you think about it you look at him
as like enterprises yeah big money man
you know what i mean corporate [ __ ] but
i'm talking about these two [ __ ] in
the street causing the whole world to
have an uproar yeah that's true two
street [ __ ] that's true
the whole world not just that's just the
street uh black or a country not not
even a [ __ ] country the whole world
two street [ __ ]
well tupac really was a school [ __ ] too
though
it's just like a smart [ __ ]
listen he's smart new poetry knew all
that you know [ __ ] too don't you
i'm serious now listen
you you know you he talks his gangster
[ __ ] but you get him right here and he
starts doing shakespeare and all this
other [ __ ] yeah definitely
i'm definitely gonna read i read a lot i
stay informed man you know yeah they had
a lot of [ __ ] from [ __ ] in books so
you know i go find them that's the
inform yeah definitely that thing form
definitely
you have to understand all of us blacks
whites but we just all had different
names but we all been here from the
beginning we are all residue of the past
what you mean by that since the
beginning of existence
with all that one bloodline
the beginning of god created a life with
all that same bloodline oh yeah
definitely
i agree with that
how could we not all be what
because we all different man we're all
different but still the same
nah everybody ain't the same
huh
oh yeah we have to we're more like than
this than not alike
we have the same needs wants and
necessities
that's why we fight
because we got the same needs we want
some necessities i think we got the same
necessities
but maybe not the same needs and once
[ __ ]
but it ends up to the same the feeling
the feeling of accomplishment and
getting what you want us to feel
everything it all goes by different ways
but from the same it's just for the same
art the exponent of that feeling
some people go to the long run some
people go to short right but it's just
the route is for that feeling right it's
the moment in time and then we're dead
but we searched our whole life fighting
to get it
and then it's over it's like crack like
a crackhead and they smoke crack for the
first time the uh the rest of the times
they're just trying to get that they
chase in the first half so you saying in
life did you ever feel the feeling first
and you chasing it or you trying to get
to it well i felt it you're not gonna
want to chase if you never got a piece
of it
when was the win did you get a piece of
that feeling when i was a young kid and
i was on um i was 15
and i had one two national championships
and then i was adult fighter and i was
on this i was on the [ __ ] scale
and i heard them people talking like i
was a you know like a slave on the
[ __ ] block look at tyson look at his
arm he won the jam he won the junior
olympics he's won the national champion
he knocked everybody out he's only 15
years old i felt some kind of grandeur
that somebody would say these great
things about me
and that was the bug i got um
when somebody started clapping [ __ ] me
up and i got turned out and fighting
the applause
yeah
the crowd yeah it's probably something
similar to you too yeah i feel that like
when i do like your shows for sure you
know this um see that stuff right here
the camera yeah you know what that is
see that stuff
that's not a camera like you think of
the camera that's a narcotic
see those cameras they don't they're
narcotics
we get attached we fall in love with
ourselves when we see it
the camera yeah
you're in love with don't even know it i
don't mean well you know what i'm gonna
keep it real with you i don't even
really like looking at myself okay no
you don't have to
it's the energy it's where you keep
going you keep you're attracted to it i
know people don't like it either but
they're attracted to it because not you
know you you're ordained from and
there's god that's been written
do you believe that
i definitely believe that for sure
i definitely believe that
i just don't like watching my like i
don't even really like watch my videos
or like watch like
it'd be weird watching myself i know i
don't understand that because you know
your flaws nobody else knows them though
you look perfect
to everyone else you know who you are
you know all right hmm they never look
at it that way
damn that's crazy
who would you want to do some
work with
right on music for what
even acting movie
man film i mean i want to work with like
samuel l jackson that's my favorite
actor man
i love him
it's like he's just like a blend of like
funny and like you know you're mad he's
great dramatic he can do it all i love
him he like
he's one of the most versatile guys you
know i mean so i definitely you know
look at him um
uh rap wise um you know
anybody that want to work with me you
know what i mean that uh you know
respect you know it's just really just
coming out down to that i don't really
like collaborating too much unless
unless it's organic man
you know what i mean for history though
you know what i mean like i said for me
it got to be organic when you're making
music i don't really you know the
business side of it it get like weird
you know what i'm saying you know so it
is what it is you know whoever like
respect me respect my music so what's
your end game at the end of the day what
how do you how do you look at the end of
the day when it's over when you retire
from of time but when you at the stage
your life where you don't have to work
what's that look like i don't even know
i can't really picture myself not work
like ever working on something you can't
picture yourself with a family and i'm
situated here and i'm really not
interested in moving too much i mean you
know i got three kids i got you know
families all over the place
so uh i mean you know i got family you
know i'm real tight with my brothers my
sisters my mom's that's always gonna be
there i don't know i just got a strong
work ethic i always want to feel like i
want to just start a new project with
this you know now with this film stuff
now i'm looking at how it's getting made
all of that stuff like that so like i'm
going to be hands-on yeah i want to like
direct produce things of that nature now
now i'm seeing like you know the ropes
of that you have a mentor that shows you
through the ropes in that particular
field you want to be involved in no i
never really mentored no like nah no
rappers have you ever had been mentored
somebody in the middle of never been
mentored by somebody in the music
industry let me show you how to really
um go about um the infrastructure of the
business yeah definitely i got big
homies in the music industry uh scarface
blind b really you know starting out
they was really uh texas helpful uh you
know gave me a lot of advice for sure
especially bun bun to this day you know
i mean definitely get a lot of advice
from you know i mean i talked to
scarface the other day get well soon
because he just had surgery oh give him
my lovely yeah definitely that's my dog
so guys like that you know that i you
know look up to came up listening to
study and those definitely two guys that
i can pick up the phone and call so i
look at you know
look at them like
they're the guys
i respect that you know what i'm saying
so what do you do man
you're not making music man really
staying in shape working out you know
you know what i'm saying to be honest i
don't be boxing to nothing like that
i'll be seeing a lot of rappers posting
boxing videos embarrassing that damn
himself i ain't one of them guys i don't
do that but you know i you know
definitely stay in shape defend myself
and all of that so
i'm good i can fight though
yeah [ __ ] be boxing on camera i'll be
like man chill the [ __ ] out man like
these things be looking crazy so they
have no idea they look crazy they look
crazy
crazy they be shaking their booty boxing
i'll be like oh man shut the [ __ ] up
looking so stupid man so rapper stop
putting stop posting these boxing videos
for a [ __ ] come test your hands for
real though straight up they can handle
she's six nine
i took i can handle takashi 69
that's like a pit bull in a chihuahua
that might look like five three man
really
[ __ ] like that get [ __ ] up
right
like ain't nothing tough about a guy
like that so here's the speech
impediment huh who who got a speech
impediment to come on takashi takashi 69
yeah
i don't know i just think you know he's
a little mexican [ __ ] he just
say [ __ ] a lot
i don't need i like some of his songs
when he first came out i like that [ __ ]
i ain't with that snitching [ __ ] but you
know he was a good artist though
[ __ ] can't really take that away
from him he's a good artist he's
definitely in an entertaining ass [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying with all that
you know when the [ __ ] get you know
until all that legal [ __ ] on you know i
don't really [ __ ] with that i keep away
from tough guys and that's been getting
yeah
[ __ ] trouble i don't [ __ ] with no
tough guys all these [ __ ] in
the rap industry rap the only [ __ ] with
[ __ ] is like
fake tough like you don't see no like
rock bands and [ __ ] like that you know
when they hear about no beef like
country singers and [ __ ] like they want
to make money together exactly you know
what i'm saying so it's like rap the
only [ __ ] with [ __ ] got these
little fake tough egos and [ __ ] that's
why i stay to myself i don't really [ __ ]
with too many of these rap [ __ ] like
that i guess this that's just the
beginning of rap the tough guy image
yeah man
a lot of that [ __ ] be fake man you know
what i'm saying so you know it don't be
the rappers it'd be like they homies
from where they from and [ __ ] like that
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up and do [ __ ] like that
you do a reality show would i do a
reality show yeah yeah i would you know
a bunch of naked [ __ ] and [ __ ] damn
look at this flavor of love
flavor love that sounds like some luke's
peeps show type [ __ ] he was around that
day luke was so incredible yeah man
me and a bunch of naked [ __ ] nah man
i got kids i wouldn't do that [ __ ]
make it whip it back
did you did you ever go on luke's peep
show i don't know i forgot but i would i
would [ __ ] i would he asked me i would
that seemed like it was the [ __ ] man i
wish i was around during that era
oh man you would not have believed you
wouldn't have to believe that people
would do [ __ ]
human beings don't do this [ __ ] man liz
like that i mean i see a lot of wild
[ __ ] in the rap world you know what i'm
saying so now i can't even say what man
have you ever seen an orgy on stage from
a replica timeout
on stage yeah like during the show
yeah hold on so you're talking about a
[ __ ] having an all-out
hey listen guys luke campbell at the end
of the show getting [ __ ]
on stage goku
on stage
you got to see it to believe it [ __ ]
yeah
it's just see but look [ __ ] that's
that's that's that's an era where [ __ ]
ain't have their phones out instagram
and all that [ __ ] so they just they
being filmed
these guys don't give a [ __ ] man you
know nothing about they don't give a
[ __ ] but that's before social media man
you'll get frappe i give man if i get my
dick sucked on stage a mother when i get
fried it'll be over with i'll never get
booked again this is like in the stadium
you just couldn't believe these brothers
damn like it was just they didn't give a
[ __ ] that was a wild [ __ ] hair
uh they yeah that was a wild [ __ ]
hair the two live crew here two live
crew having sex on stage
two live crew having sex on stage they
got a video of this [ __ ] on the internet
no [ __ ] way well i thought i'm film
how do you think i know
back in the 90s was like the baddest
[ __ ] that everybody wanted why was the
90s that was a halle berry oh i think
hud too
you dated hell too no oh she was
partnered to this oh [ __ ] but um i love
halle berry naomi campbell uh everybody
knew the camera was bad it's a really
nice one that we got
really awesome white ones too back in
the 80s yeah there was some good ones
yeah white girls in the 80s was good
and [ __ ] michelle pfeiffer and all that
type [ __ ]
dr umar gonna get mad at us for talking
about white girls
i'll go back to him you never heard of
dr lamar
he doesn't know like white people or
black people talk about white yeah
they don't like white people huh you
don't like white people so what's his
problem
i don't know man he's just a righteous
black i mean he got some cool ideas but
yeah
it can be cool
that [ __ ] ain't cool that part of it
ain't cool none of it's cool any hate
involved it can't be cool i don't care
if
if his dictation rhymes and it sounds
like it can't be i can't believe you
ain't never heard of dr umar you should
have dr umar come on this [ __ ]
that'd be tight
i don't know i'm not cool i gotta see dr
uma's
work and stuff he just don't like you
know uh interracial dating man which is
stupid to me
yeah you know
then who is it who is he who need to
have that thought who was he to have
that opinion just make sure man and
think that it counts i guess hit the
[ __ ] a doctor i don't know man [ __ ] i
just be looking at [ __ ] laughing at some
[ __ ] it's funny to me yeah he dig it i
guess so
well what i will say about him he got
some good like uh business approach
ideas for black people i can't slam him
he got some you know good ideas i don't
know him somewhere he's he's is he
wealthy
i can't say i don't know you know all
right look at these guys hey look at
this right here
what's happening late
okay
i've seen some [ __ ] like that on stage
i'm throwing my getting bones man oh man
damn that's a whole
[ __ ] out okay a little bit
okay
what what liquid is that is that water
beer man that's beer in a jug i think it
is
all right yeah yeah let's just look at
that [ __ ] man honestly you guys see
these guys getting head at the end of
the show man the whole [ __ ] who is these
[ __ ] these two lovers
i don't know who these guys are though
look what's happening here dude this is
never normal
look at the audience
okay
look like what is that what they're
gonna flow what's happening floats my
[ __ ] ass or something on the floor
man
damn i know [ __ ] was eating that
he's got his pants on me
oh he's getting his dick sucked he's
digging for gold what do you mean
getting his dicks up yeah that's what
they did in the 90s
oh man
what's that he getting blowed or what if
he didn't blow the what this [ __ ] is on
youtube is he getting blown to what
i told you man i'm not lying i've seen
this [ __ ] before
[ __ ] you cannot believe this [ __ ] that
[ __ ] on youtube youtube they took this
[ __ ] down yeah this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] now you think anybody can [ __ ]
with the two live crew from here nobody
in this generation
no you couldn't do that [ __ ] listen some
bad ass rappers they asked me in prison
that [ __ ] probably got a ticket
right yeah we can't do that dude not in
the me too era dawg you can't do that
no no no look at this [ __ ] stick stuck
still no no no
we i get down with that but not on stage
that's some crazy look how many people
that do it in front of them
i really admire these guys so much that
was crazy
these guys are the [ __ ]
my masters
[Laughter]
wow orgy god damn okay
they got paid for that [ __ ]
yes they should
yes they should man oh how many
nominations did you get brother freddie
just one yeah good enough i could let go
i could tell my grandkids about that
[ __ ]
yeah you know what i'm saying i could
respect that you went to the grammys
before
it's so [ __ ] boring
it looks exciting i'm telling you
believe his number is waiting on [ __ ]
day starving the ice cream guy the
potato guys on the [ __ ] other side of
so long
and it's just some boring [ __ ] yeah it's
potential right we just want to just
dress up that's all we just did dressed
up and said my mom
it was like this weren't you well it was
covered though we couldn't we had to
just throw our own grammy party and [ __ ]
really yeah it was vegetable you could
do [ __ ] smoke weed that drink yeah you
just like this and then right here
yeah so i guess that was even that was
better because yeah you know [ __ ] had
the whole family and [ __ ] we just had
our own little [ __ ] only we were going
like the soul the black award the soul
trail
awards that's what's happening that's
number pure excitement oh [ __ ] energy
what about the bt awards bt same shit's
[ __ ] [ __ ] man what [ __ ] the bt awards
[ __ ] oh what's that man i'm like all
that [ __ ] man [ __ ] them [ __ ] they
don't eat y'all you know
you got beef with them [ __ ] be hating
on me man
that's okay
do you know what you do with that
motivation yeah the biggest advantage is
massive success exactly
math of success
how often you train every day
yeah i go right there
you got a sparring partner mm-hmm oh
[ __ ]
young [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] me up
he good
good enough
that's crazy
so you you you know that you say you
don't cook make no collabs like with
[ __ ]
i have i ain't gonna say i don't don't i
do come on man let's listen to freddie
gibbs music i got you know [ __ ]
[Music]
that's a good one i was holding my son
oh yeah let me hear that it's the la
leakers just incredible sour milk from
gary indiana to l.a
our family freddie gibbs is here you
know how we do this thing man freddie
junior junior oh came to set it off man
you ready to do this son he was mad he
wouldn't let me he wouldn't let me put
him down man
i was trying to give him the lambo so i
had to hold him and [ __ ]
that's right yeah yeah
yeah yeah
type of [ __ ] cook a birdie for
breakfast and throw the fan up don't
[ __ ] with maserati alexis i pull the
bins on my mama birthday coming i might
just get it of being struggle cut off my
[ __ ] losses and put a window
kicking like a writer that trying to
white in the blender send that [ __ ] to
michigan city into the panel mama set
the federal prison but i would end up
attorney like 600 hours just to defend
us like my god all a [ __ ] know it's top
part i need a [ __ ] with a pretty face a
banky count in the backyard cause now a
[ __ ] swiping black car 911 black on
black is a black attack i'm the black
guy not a fat [ __ ] but i've been
getting max cream addicts lining up to
get injected like a vaccine chop on me
daily ain't safe deliver rap dream
[ __ ] popping hella rap cap for the rap
cree gays on my phone plays on my phone
rules on my phone gang on my phone
trey's on my phone land put me on josh
put me on till she put me on guys he put
me on god put me on now i can sit back
in my mansion and get blacked in my
chest getting it cracking i'm sipping
is
[Music]
[Music]
kill this [ __ ] and let it breathe [ __ ]
young is about to slice and emojis with
the skis [ __ ] real king of the street
[ __ ] got three books for the 20 west
brook rest in peace nip real king of
street [ __ ] the marathon never stop you
put these [ __ ] on their feet [ __ ] i
swear to [ __ ] and got the streets sick
the last supper you might get it from
some [ __ ] that you eat with cocaine
whole thing freddy kolioni soprano my
whole name 40 yaddles on the pickup i'm
dogging the whole lane all this will to
the lords and stones and foes man got
some [ __ ] that ain't never gonna talk
on the phone man piece of charlie mike
i'm [ __ ] until you get home man for
the autos on the pickup i'm talking the
whole lane all this well to the lords
over one of them drake beats i think
you know
rap [ __ ] easy [ __ ]
i don't know about no easy [ __ ] but
shit's easy man
for you [ __ ]
i mean uh you know it's a you know it's
a intricate process but still i forgot
not a thing not everybody could think
yeah yeah it's definitely [ __ ] be
thinking [ __ ] quick tenth of a second
thoughts and stuff people brains don't
work like that
i know but it's competitive with me i
don't know i just i approach it like a
sport you know what i'm saying like i
just try to just rap like nobody rap
like do like patterns nobody do you know
flow like nobody else flow that's really
you know if you look at it i ain't
planning on doing this stuff you think
before you get back into acting
um
i don't know
i don't know
i love i love her i mean you know i
don't think i'm ever be away from the
music but you know [ __ ] who knows
i might decide to start a restaurant or
some [ __ ] you know what i'm saying have
a tough business it is a tough business
tough business you're in the restaurant
business before i've i've
some of my friends get smashed i saw and
become successful so
i still miss it's just it's and it's
just a greedy machine keeps eating
especially if the clientele's not
consistent that's true
that's true
if
the restaurant is on
and just get my monthly bill right
exactly yeah that's the way to do it
real estate [ __ ] like that
yeah that's the future i never really
thought about that until my wife put me
on to this stuff yeah
yeah i don't know i think i'm a i'm a
pro i'm a rap forever i don't think i'm
gonna ever stop right now i'm just it's
just gonna be just
in what capacity i'm gonna do it here
you know
i'ma always do
it i think i do it better than a lot of
people so
yeah
i'm gonna come to like actually rapping
so you know
i'm gonna play a role as a rap promoter
in a movie yeah
for real
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you like acting
yeah i like that i like stage acting not
movies that much yeah oh you like stage
acting yeah like plays you don't like
movies that much yeah i like that movie
i made movies i get paid from the movie
but my enjoyment's on stage i like that
movie where you played yourself
from the 90s uh
damn what was the name of that [ __ ] well
you slapped a [ __ ] when you came up to
me oh what was that [ __ ] black and white
black and white
yeah with power in this [ __ ] yeah and
black well who else [ __ ]
bob rob down here
wanted a basketball boy allen houston
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy why you slapped
that [ __ ] like that that still seemed
real they told me to
oh yeah
yeah i was focused you can't do that
but yeah i remember that part vividly in
the movie though so
but i ain't never thought about doing
those stage play that should seem cool
beautiful yeah
so you're smart you pissed you got good
perception you could tell when you're on
stage and you're in the movie you got
you're looking at this [ __ ] you know i
mean it's looking at you correct so it's
like the the camera has to tell you what
to say but on stage the people tell you
what they want so they i can't explain
they tell you what the ones you do and
they applaud they love it it's just so
much easier than doing the film
you can read off the people you could
know what to say to them
you know it's all about energy and
connecting with them that's something
you can never do with this
hmm
that's crazy
it seemed difficult oh no it's just
you feel the people
you feel you know you're entertaining
you're feeling yeah i'm just feeling
them
and doing that i'm gonna do that
probably one once twice in my career
hopefully
if they pick me for one of those hours
you start doing and you won't be once or
twice
you'll be stuck
there's nobody i know that both did that
they they stuck on the stage every time
they could get a stage up boom yeah i
like comedy [ __ ] i got my own little
comedy show i'll be doing you [ __ ] yeah
you gotta come do it you gotta come come
first performance at the comedy store in
l.a yeah i'll be having the comics
coming really it's really just me like
displaying comics that i like you know
what i'm saying kind of like how martin
was doing with the def comedy jam [ __ ]
you know i like that i was a huge fan of
that so
you know i want to go in that light yeah
i remember that stuff back in the day
when it first started yeah there's this
guy robin harris he um robin harris
one of my favorite comedians listen he
started everybody off he'll be none of
these guys if it wasn't for him he put
them all on
display yeah yeah yeah robin harris [ __ ]
he wanted the best heaven my pops used
to listen his tastes listen
broke my heart yeah
he was the [ __ ] and do the right thing
too
sweet dick willie yeah talking [ __ ]
talking mad [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] baby's kid
she was wild you had to see him and
comedy acted when he went there like the
whole black spot
everybody jamie [ __ ] everybody has to go
there
you know to get christian
any kind of
statue of the um comedian yeah you know
bernie mac was the [ __ ] who he was good
too yeah a little birdie but it was good
bernie
success has a lot to do with um
duration and being around for a while i
remember frank sinatra told me he said
not how good you do is how long you do
good
longevity and longevity right
yeah that's real it's hard to have
longevity in the rap game man it's
difficult you got to sustain
well it was easy everybody be doing that
that's true everything is difficult
there's nothing easy in this world you
want to fight again
hell yeah oh for real yeah
damn
that's crazy it is
yeah i definitely got to see that
my last fight i broke all the wreckage
when i was jammed with my records
and i was a young [ __ ] man that's crazy
you ever gonna fight a young lady
no i probably i want to fight um spoiler
um tyson fury
oh yeah he told me what keep doing while
i was here give me an exhibition that'd
be hard what do you think about deontay
wilde
i think he's pretty good i don't know if
he'll be tasting through if he is going
to start winging and playing he has a
chance but he's laying back turn the box
was not going to work what about deontay
wilder versus you in 1985.
i would beat him
for sure
i don't think i don't know to me like i
said man i i didn't think it was too
many people that could beat you period i
was not a good trainer you're my
favorite boxer thank you thank you
i was watching the special muhammad
aliyah last night yeah yeah oh and it
was just
i knew it happened but it's still like
yesterday right yeah
yeah i gotta watch that i definitely
gotta check that out man
i watched the fight i watched the old
fight last week um
i wanted the best fights i ever seen um
marvin hagler hit me in here
oh my god that's probably i watched that
it's like man cause it's like i miss it
i feel like boxing kind of fell off a
little bit yeah it did because the best
fighters are not fighting the best
fighters
sean porter's fighting somebody who's he
fighting crawford yeah that's gonna be a
great fight yeah i want to see that i
want to see blood crawford versus
aerospace yeah um sean porter he's the
real did they fight anybody yeah he's
the only guy that [ __ ] [ __ ] and he'll
fight anybody yeah i like sean porter
than anybody yeah they just got to put
the right fights together man you know
what i'm saying i want to see crawford
well i know he's not going to knock out
if he knocks sean porter out there i
think he's a bad cat i'm sick of seeing
all these jake paul fights and all them
types that's the money fight
those are the fights to make the money
those guys got 75 million people
watching them would you fight one of
them yeah hell yeah oh man that'd be
crazy i want to see that
i don't think they'll do that they would
have a lot of money that'd be a lot of
money we got to set that up man
you versus which one jacob logan which
one your size i don't even know i can't
tell them
the 190s wasn't like one night oh yeah
oh yeah i think ain't that the one that
just fought the mma guy
no no that's
that was one the fourth exploit
i
mm-hmm
want to fight football floyd yeah i
don't think he'll fight you i don't
think he'll do that he might money
hundred million bucks they do anything
they don't care about that yeah you're
right 100 million dollars [ __ ]
i want to see [ __ ] get knocked out all
right so this is another episode of hot
boxing we're here mike tyson and brother
here freddie gibbs man and thank you
freddie man thank you for blessing me
with your presence thank you for
blessing me man just gonna stay here
longer and smoke more it's all good man
[ __ ] we all go
thank you man
yeah thank you what the [ __ ] that's
crazy they tell you all these millions
of people here
tell them what you're about what you
want to see if they can find you where
just google me man
it's only one [ __ ] me there's
only one freddie gibbs
do you want them to know anything about
your next project or anything coming up
i don't want them to know [ __ ] about my
next project [ __ ] you off i want them
[ __ ] i want this [ __ ] to hit
the ass from the blind side cause i know
these [ __ ] studying my moves
right now you know what i'm saying so
talk that [ __ ] again trying to blindside
you [ __ ] so i don't want you to
know [ __ ] about [ __ ] until you see it
and that's what i'm not forget yes sir
[Music]
you